hi everyone
this is professor m.science and today i
want to discuss the creation and
annihilation operators of bosons
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the creation and
annihilation operators are central
in second quantization they essentially
do what their name says they do
they create and annihilate particles as
such they allow us to explore
the fox space we'll also learn how to
use them to write the stage of a
multi-particle system in a compact form
something that will help us simplify the
mass down the line this video covers the
bosonic operators but there is a
companion video that covers the
fermionic operator so you should check
it out
let's go we start with the fox space
f given by the direct sum over all n
particle state spaces
and for bosons these n particle state
spaces are in turn spanned by totally
symmetric states
we consider a set of states u forming a
basis for a single particle state space
v
and we also write the fox state n1 n2
and so
on in the occupation number
representation and remember that this
means that there are ni particles in
state
ui the creation operator associated with
single particle state ui
is a ui dagger and it is defined by its
action
on a fox state and it is equal to this
what this means is that the creation
operator associated with single particle
state ui
acts on a fox state by adding a particle
to the ui state
so that the associated occupation number
ni increases by 1.
we also have this proportionality
constant in the definition which for now
you can take as a given
and we will see later that this choice
helps simplify the maths
another way to understand what the
creation operator is doing is that it
allows us to navigate
fox space if we start with this fox
state with n particles
it lives in the subspace fn of the fox
space
then a ui dagger adds a particle to the
system in state ui
so it allows us to generate this new fox
state which lives in
fn plus one let me also make a quick
comment about notation
when there is no possible confusion we
will very often write expressions like
the definition of the creation operator
in this simplified form
here we're only including the occupation
and i of the ui state that is being
changed by the creation operator
and we then understand that the
occupations of all other single particle
states don't change so we don't
explicitly write them down
the next thing i want to discuss is the
add joint operator
of the creation operator which is given
by
a ui the question we have is what does
this operator do
to figure it out let's write the matrix
element of the creation operator between
these two fox states
and i am using the simplified notation
in which i only include the occupation
number of the state that the creation
operator affects
using the action of a dagger on ni up
here
we get the normalization factor and then
this bracket
the bracket gives one because fox states
from an orthonormal basis so we end up
with this
now let's write the matrix element again
let's use the conjugation property of
the scalar product to rewrite it like
this
and now let's use the fact that the
adjoint of an adjoint gives the original
operator
to end up with this these two
expressions for the matrix element imply
that
n i a u i n i plus 1 equals square root
of n i plus 1 all complex conjugate
but this is a real number because
occupation numbers are 0 or positive
integers so we can straight away rewrite
this without the complex conjugate
fox states form an orthonormal basis so
the only way in which this matrix
element won't vanish
is if a ui acting on ni plus 1
gives the term proportional to ni and
then to obtain this expression the
proportionality constant must be square
root of ni plus 1.
putting this together we see that a ui
acting on the ket n i plus 1
must be equal to this to make the
expression equivalent to the one we have
for the creation operator we're going to
decrease ni by 1
so we obtain this final expression here
so what does a ui do it removes a
particle that was occupying single
particle state ui
so it allows us to go from fn to fn
minus one
for this reason we call aui the
annihilation operator
the next quantity i want to look at are
the commutation relations between the
creation and annihilation operators
before doing that i will simplify
notation to make the expressions more
manageable and replace a ui dagger
by a i dagger and aui by ai
where we implicitly understand that
we're always working in the u basis of
single particle states
first consider two creation operators ai
dagger and aj dagger
we write the action of a i dagger aj
dagger on a fox state
and again we only explicitly write out
the occupation numbers on which the
creation operators act
using the definition above twice we
obtain these two pre-factors
and then the state with two extra
particles one in each of the two single
particle states
next let's calculate the same action but
now exchanging the order in which we
apply the creation operators
and we now get this expression
calculating this equation minus this
equation
we obtain that the commutator of ai
dagger and aj dagger vanishes
in this derivation we have implicitly
assumed that i and j are different
but if they were the same then the
creation operators commute trivially
because they are the same operator so
the expression is in fact valid for
any i and j so what does this mean
in the companion video on creation and
annihilation operators for fermions
we find that rather than obeying
commutation relations like bosons
fermions instead obey anti-commutation
relations
this difference between the operator
algebra of bozonic and fermionic
creation and annihilation operators
reflects the respective symmetric
and antisymmetric nature of their states
specifically
the reason why we have the vanishing of
the commutator in bosons is because
symmetric states don't change when we
exchange any two particles
so when writing these expressions we
don't have to worry about the order of
the occupation numbers
in the case of fermions whenever we
exchange two particles we get an extra
minus sign
so in that case we need to add these two
equations rather than subtract them to
get the vanishing result
hence the reason why for fermions we
have an anti-commutator rather than a
commutator
okay so having established the
commutation relation for creation
operators what about annihilation
operators
we could repeat the same exercise we
just did for the creation operator but i
will take a different strategy
let's first write the adjoint of the
commutator of the creation operators
then let's write out the commutator
then separate the expression into two
terms like this
and remember that the adjoint of a
product exchanges the order of the terms
so we get a j a i minus
a i aj which is the commutator of aj
and ai this commutator is equal to 0
so we can exchange the order of the
terms and write the conventional result
that the commutator between a i
and aj vanishes
what about the commutator between an
emulation and the creation operator
in this case we have to distinguish two
possibilities let's start with i
different from j
we can look at a i a j dagger acting on
a fox state
and then using the action of the
creation and the relation operators we
get these two pre-factors
and then a fox state with one viewer
particle in single particle state ui
and one extra particle in single
particle state uj
we can then look at direction in reverse
order
and we get this calculating this
equation
minus this equation we obtain that the
commutator of a
i and aj dagger vanishes if i is
different from j
what about i equals j in this case we
can write a i ai
dagger acting on an i acting with ai
dagger we get a factor of square root of
ni plus 1 and create a particle in the
ui state
and then acting with a i we get another
factor of square root of ni plus 1
and annihilate that particle we can then
repeat this exercise but now in the
reverse order
we first annihilate a particle and then
create it back
while keeping track of the correct
pre-factors
calculating this equation minus this
equation
from these two expressions we obtain
that the commutator of a i and a j
dagger is equal to one
if i equals j putting together this
result
and this result we can write them
together for arbitrary values of i and j
as the commutator of a i and aj dagger
equal to delta ij
before we summarize all the commutators
we have obtained now that we got such a
simple expression here
because of the choice we made at the
very beginning for the normalization of
the action of the creation operator up
here
if we had made a different choice for
the normalization this commutator would
give some other number rather than one
for i equals j
in fact we could have gone the other way
and taken the commutation relation as
the given assumption
and then derived the normalization
constant above what this means is that
making the assumption that the
normalization step
or at the commutator step is equivalent
and then we can work our way from one to
the other or vice versa
okay so combining all the results we
just derived we arrive at this set of
commutation relations for bozonic
creation
and annihilation operators you should
really familiarize yourself with this
because they're used all the time when
doing quantum mechanics in the second
quantization language
the next thing i want to look at is the
structure of fox space and how the
creation and emulation operators allow
us to navigate it
let's work with a fixed single particle
state and let's first write the
corresponding vacuum state that contains
zero particles acting with the creation
operator on the vacuum state
allows us to go to this state containing
one particle and i'm not specifying a
sub-index in the creation operator here
because i assume that we're working with
the same single particle state all the
time for this discussion
acting again with the same creation
operator takes us to this situation with
two particles in the state
and we can continue in this fashion to
go up the ladder indefinitely
we can also start from a given
occupation for this state and walk down
the ladder by applying the annihilation
operator like this
all the way to the vacuum state however
once we get to the vacuum state we can
no longer remove more particles because
there are none left
this means that acting with the
inhalation operator on the vacuum state
kills the state and the actual
denialation operator terminates
at the vacuum state this discussion
shows that the structure of the bosonic
fox space
is quite different to that of the
fermionic fox space that i discussed in
the companion video link in the
description
the fermionic fox space terminates in
both directions because we cannot have
more than one fermion in a single
particle state due to pauli exclusion
in contrast the bosonic space goes on
indefinitely to the right
because we can add as many bosons as we
like to a given state
this discussion also helps us construct
arbitrary occupation number states
starting from the vacuum state and
acting on it
with the creation operator and we just
argued acting with the creation operator
on the vacuum state creates this state
with one particle in ui
acting with the creation operator twice
gives the state with one particle
and in the state with two particles in
ui with the corresponding normalization
constant
repeating this procedure we get that
acting ni times with the creation
operator
gives the fox state with ni particles in
state ui
with the corresponding proportionality
constant obtained by combining all the
intermediate ones
by simplifying the definition we can
then move the proportionality constant
dividing the other side of the equation
and we get the occupation number state
built from the vacuum state
putting this together for an arbitrary
occupation number state
we first get this proportionality
constant
and then we act an appropriate number of
times with each creation operator
on the vacuum states what this is
telling us
is that we get occupation n1 for single
particle state u1
by acting n1 times with the
corresponding creation operator on the
vitamin state
and so on for all other single particle
states
this final expression also allows us to
relate occupation number states between
first and second quantization
remember that in first quantization we
can write the occupation number state
as equal to this proportionality
constant and then the symmetrizer acting
on the tensor product state like this
we can identify the right hand side of
these two expressions and we get that
one is equal to the other
we can now compare first and second
quantization the first quantization
expression on the right
ensures that we have a totally symmetric
state through the n factorial terms
arising from the application of the
symmetrizer s
plus the second quantization expression
on the left
captures all the subtleties associated
with the symmetry of the state
through the creation operators which we
have seen about a set of commutation
relations that are a direct
consequence of this exchange symmetry
the final thing i want to discuss before
wrapping up is the occupation number
operator
we define it as nui equal to aui dagger
aui to see why this operator is called
the occupation number operator
consider its action on a fox state ni
where again i use the simplified
notation in which i emit the u basis and
i only specify the occupation numbers
that are affected by the creation and
annihilation operators that we're
working with
spelling out the operator ni gives this
then we annelate a particle in the usual
way and we get this
and then we create a particle in the
usual way and we get this
what this is showing is that the fox
states are the eigenstates of the
occupation number operator
and the eigenvalues ni simply tell us
how many particles there are in that
state
with this result we can construct the
operator associated with the total
number of particles by summing over all
single particle occupation number
operators
or explicitly in terms of creation and
annihilation operators
to wrap up let's compare the bosonic
creation and denation operator we've
been discussing
with the corresponding fermionic
operators for which you can find a
detailed discussion in the companion
video linked in the description
as we have found the creation and
annulation operators for bosons obey
these commutation relations
which are a direct consequence of the
symmetric nature
of bosonic states by contrast in the
video inframuni creation and
annihilation operators
we find that they instead obey these
anti-commutation relations
represented by the curly brackets which
are a consequence
of the anti-symmetric nature of
fermionic states
the commutation algebra of creation and
annihilation operators captures all the
subtleties associated with the symmetry
of bosonic states this forms the basis
of the description of bosons
in second quantization don't forget to
check out the video on fermions if you
haven't yet
and if you like the video please
subscribe